this is probably the pettiest and most
vindictive thing i have ever heard in a
legal context and it comes straight from
elon musk now elon musk's hatred of the
sec the securities and exchange
commission is well known musk and the
sec have butted heads many times but
when one of tesla's outside law firms
cooley which is one of the largest law
firms in the country hired a former
lawyer for the sec elon musk wasn't
having it so he called up one of the
partners at this huge law firm and said
if you don't fire this lawyer who has
nothing to do with tesla doesn't work on
any of the tesla cases and whose only
offense was that he used to work for the
sec if you don't fire him i will fire
the entire law firm and not let them
work with tesla anymore i guess when
you're worth 300 billion dollars you can
choose whatever law firm that you want
but apparently that lawyer who's just an
associate not even a partner at the law
firm still works there but man elon musk
that is really petty and that is really
vindictive